I'll do it okay who's ready let me know
Happy New Year Happy New Year everybody
happy new year is 2020 2020
what's our full podcast the first party
of the year we have our guests we're
here Alan Cummings but you go by AC
right I understand Lisa Esparza Oh
Daniel we have miss Carlito right here
what's up
east of the river you could check out
his stuff on Spotify and and you can
char right now yeah all his albums are
there even one I read of this one a diss
song he did to that guy from the Black
Eyed Peas
oh yeah it's the black happy black boy
yeah yeah yeah I just respond it was
more like a reminder yeah
before he start wearing a weird clothes
okay it was wearing we're closing in -
was he yeah Heights and he said there's
nothing to rap about in Boyle Heights
which I thought was kind of like but
this yeah like you grew up here run
you're dissing the artists that are here
who are already making music right so I
just doing a little jab at the at the
start nothing too crazy but I was like
look next time you say there's nothing
to rap about in Boyle Heights play this
and then the DJ's put on [ __ ] you know
the the the two short
wrap it about Ferraris now uh-huh well
we're moving up now that's not what
managers here I don't know what you're
saying they recorded my dad cheese song
singing outside and put it in the album
there's like an anthem for our
neighborhood out in Boyle Heights
what's up fool podcast everybody who's
listening right now I told you guys I'm
gonna start doing something different
like I'm a motivate you guys to get off
your ass and go for a walk or take a
deep breath start drinking water
leave that sorted out man though you
can't be drinking two litres of Diet
Coke and expect to be skinny worth your
life man so me ought to get knee surgery
all right what's up I talk about right
here man we don't make fun of we talk
about stuff we know about man I don't
know about the bus drivers or stuff like
that
he's hanging out with I don't know man
the Klan vida listening right now Jesse
said want this Gracie shoulder was
question 1,000 why am I not on should we
be hurry the hot dog
what's up I miss it enchilada casserole
I miss eating enchilada casserole
anyways everybody this is a book if
anybody wants to join the what's up poop
podcast book of the month
it's um I'm fatty right now I fatty by
Jerry Stahl it's this book is very
inexpensive man you could get it for a
dollar 75 how much I paid for my blog on
the chipping and came out to 675 this
book is so don't even exist anymore it's
off print they took it one of the
library because of the hard core it is
is a story of a comedian from the silent
era Roscoe Fatty Arbuckle
he was the first comedian to make a
million dollars for a movie producer
write it and then he got into a scandal
he was posting he raped somebody and
broke him borrowing her
and killed her in San Francisco and his
trial became like the first Oh Jake
Tapper trial where he was guilty by the
press blah-blah-blah-blah-blah long
story short he helped start Charlie
Chaplin's career Buster Keaton in this
book he talks about how he told Charlie
Chaplin to put on his big ass shoes in
the end I'm trying to chop and put him
in backwards and I became his title so
check out that book man we'll talk about
it later on go check it out
Jerry Stahl he wrote a book called
permanent midnight and that's a book I'm
listening to an audible which gets back
to what we're talking about well dude
the guy who wrote this book he's too
right bro he took a [ __ ] bus and and
took a [ __ ] Columbus Ohio Ohio area
to work for a hustler bro like he was
riding with Larry Flynt bro
a bunch of Jews he showed up in a suit
everybody wearing cowboy boots and
[ __ ] out vest departing and he was
the only Jewish dude there so the other
night was Julian and speak to him all
the way to the fascist so damn he talks
about doing that right yeah it's just
about getting a higher foreplay were to
do a fork a lob an article with Mickey
Rourke bro and Mickey Rourke is a piece
of work bro like he's like Willie
Barcena to a third power bro that guy
anyway
yeah bro like did we Mickey Rourke has 5
hole we see gangs out with they grew up
somewhere like they were all bad dudes
like they were on drugs they were
teasing him or the president but he
helped him he there on his payroll boom
boom boom he get some fat envelopes
he has one guy they like his bodyguard
who'd do anything for him like like spit
on somebody or whatever you need any
time no questions asked nearly homies
like Apple fool he'll do it bro
forced Toula jerry star he'll say you're
gonna make a girlfriend let me check on
her but make it rugged myself if he gets
bit by a rattlesnake on the tip of his
penis I'm gonna be right there sucking
that [ __ ] poison out so he come back
to life you know what I'm [ __ ] saying
you got a problem with that and then
there's another guy brother he would
mention the name Mickey Rourke has him
there just to [ __ ] on him all day like
like [ __ ] Chapel here man that
[ __ ] loser bro tell everybody how
much of a loser you are bro Carlos Jose
whatever your name is but like David I
didn't even save it tell you this guy
what were you doing before nothing
you're a [ __ ] loser a worthless piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] Ricky wrote throw the
sword out here a piece of cake bro she
should like [ __ ] and he berates up for
three hours straight bro everything you
hired him just to treat like [ __ ] damn
you know that's kind of kudo by the time
you meet somebody out of your crew
you're a nice person that's what I'm
saying cuz you didn't depth all your
[ __ ] on this do and so you nicely
everybody else I mean I might have to do
that master big Johnny boy when that
corpse is cold
I'll ride to get a friend if I'm really
not mad like yeah growing up
you usually have those type of homies
yeah there's that one homey always [ __ ]
on everybody bags on but he's either G
he's down but y'all his bag huh yeah
he's really in charge of rolling blood
so you won't let anybody else outside
the group bag probably yeah you'll [ __ ]
everybody else oh yeah you're not a
vampire
yeah you're not a part of the group
can't talk to him like usually that guy
has another group of friends I don't
hang out with those groups and then he a
little zoom
everybody to get [ __ ] on belong to crew
that they [ __ ] on it keeps going sort of
somebody shoots you in the head and
kicks you in the creek now we don't have
one of the barbs they do they wrote to
him brother he broke his leg room
everybody's positive on podcast and I'm
like live like you know but you know
people [ __ ] on people behind closed
doors shut up positive time man you're
gonna break no bridges brave you build
your own bridge hey now you body and
build your own bridge bro you got
jetpacks now bro I'll swim to the next I
broke one right there over there off of
Santa Barbara that one little island
that's what I want to kick it oh yeah a
better one up a see my dog out dog
Detroit's finest
what's sane we performed that up in
Detroit but right before they closed it
that um that's theta with a Red Wings
play oh did Joe Lewis solo yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah man we were back there bro the
lockers just looking at the history
matters a shitload of hockey players a
better place that's what Newt Mario
Lemieux ha ha that's for NWA god yeah
riot I got a recipe got arrested and Joe
Louis Arena in Detroit don't you April
yeah yeah you did you used you perform
in a historic place man heard which I
what happened that night bro for those
who live in to historian 2018 my ex my
camera can't grew on stage in Detroit
I can't guru I heard about that there's
a guy from the Troy though they were
enviro for walking around with a
kangaroo like go see Kel go to girl I'm
looking for a kangaroo go seek a
kangaroo ostriches and they're like
exotic animal that he brings over to a
birthday party
koala zoos in the Midwest or sad they're
sad things yeah but this time can't guru
had a heroin problem Rosie Papa we want
to do heroin hero heroine we fed him
like shoutout to Daniel Mambo head-on we
were say mama chicken wings from
Sweetwater huh you got close to him no
yeah we got really close I get a man I
gave him a banana and that waited and it
was jumping around it was two of them
they were like giant rats 6-foot rats
and we went right we we took off because
we don't want to steal that long it's
hard to get a catcher over a lift when
there's 14,000 people leaving a stadium
yeah so we leave before the show ends
where we're back in you know we ate our
edibles and I passed out woke up in the
middle of night and I had a lot of hate
mail already like from Peter people
other vegans who treated animals bad but
they don't know what happened I went to
my cabs page
he brought the kangaroo on stage and
started jumping with him and everybody
thought it was jumping too okay we got
scared and almost but he was almost
killed Detroit got down like that I mean
we know everybody gangster even our
animals we gangster needy I thought we'd
do it you know I mean no Buddha will
kill you I guess small ones had to end
up paying some money to PETA and like
apologize
damn and the kangaroo whooped his ass
yeah well no that's brought him out on
stage how was the thing that was like
but that the owner of the zoo or
whatever was he wasn't being responsible
either right no
they let you know if a kangaroo was in
my show I'm gonna have to address it you
know I'm gonna bring them on stage
that's what we have to do we comedians
we just can't act like a kangaroo is not
backstage I did the same thing one time
I do the homeless day outside bro like
super change outside of one of Gabriel
Iglesias shows hey Bros on stage and
you're going along already about that
homeless guy on stage bro
like I told him man I told him I said
man here's $10 just walk up on stage
like you're about to perform so gay was
doing a bit there's almost money
homeless guy behind Oprah red button
society cut that in Cairo said okay
Cairo tell a joke he got the microphone
and then they got tell the joke
everybody laughs I hear when I get off
the star is born again they gave you man
hell yeah he was madly played with it
them anybody it made it said better okay
didn't get mad at you nah okay man up
newspaper and all that stuff what people
offended like a kangaroo I always do
that bro every Sunday brought like I
wanted yeah bro I was doing something
too crazy that that like I see like 45
minutes it's one hour what time are
Monaco see you and I we were back there
we found some bad [ __ ] bro like I'm
Game of Thrones another play that we're
having at amphitheatre and we put him on
bro and we started fighting bro like
with our with our hoods on and we were
playing a sword fight right behind his
act that time bro we perform like a
mouth we found the Beatlemania wigs bro
from the fat five minutes Vegas into the
wigs yeah and I put in mind I went up
behind him like a fat ass Beto Beto
and he was cool with that he never got
annoyed the ever I'm not there now
anymore right I got replaced by G Reilly
my dog my dog
gee Reilly man damn not to Brian
Figueroa from the Midwest know the from
East Coast yeah you know they're hangin
over that big dude like Gary Busey
nothing but right they were cool battles
guys like to drink brother food wake up
in the morning bro and break the alarm
clock and take a shot of whiskey bro -
Diaz
buenos dias shut up - Jesse child Yanis
what's up oh [ __ ] Rachel Wolfson yeah
and well so - my order Jose Sotomayor
was so full well alright so what did you
start on stand-up comedy bro man I
started stand-up man like in 1980 there
basically yeah like in 96 me - did you
[ __ ] yeah hell yeah that is like it what
the [ __ ] was going on bro I know what
the I know what I was doing no idea even
if I have fun if anybody have five
minutes of good stuff yeah I wouldn't
know how to say that here do I was so
horrible I was on stage in Detroit right
oh yeah they don't [ __ ] it yeah they
don't give a damn there's a pretty troy
throw the wing bones New York that Corey
Holcomb was talking about they were
throwing a chicken wings chicken wings -
yes at the comedian yeah give it up for
this [ __ ] as close yeah thought man
what's up they did they rude as hell but
I was in this was doing comedy in
Detroit man when I first started and you
know I was I was about two minutes in my
act
I only had 5 minutes and the place was
packed and the people in the front was
laughing but the people in back couldn't
hear me and it was
we can't hear you we can't hear you
right I started all over from the
beginning
keep it up rewind I was just loud err
and if the people didn't react I was so
scared I couldn't react I couldn't you
know I'm saying
too green to green I just kept going
that a comedy club or a black room this
was a black comedy club oh no sorry this
is a this was a it was in the summer we
was performing at a convertible Club
with no roof and it was outside it was
ass and titties everywhere right after
her dancing right after yeah yeah yeah
and I was nervous I used to get so
scared performing in your trade man you
never [ __ ] with bees comedy kitchen oh
yeah I love Bea that's why I started
these comedy kitchen downtown Tony Brown
man some of the room when I first
started man they were always comedy show
and then club right after mm-hm and like
or like oh your ticket got you in the
club already and man sometimes people
knew like they knew like the bush
community we're gonna be there don't
show up like towards the end yeah so
you'll be on stage and while it's packed
now huh money to somebody like I was
doing a podcast today in the morning
forgot the name of it but the whole day
they made local local area from the Bay
Area and some of the partying ideas
gonna be on KML in a Bay Area this
weekend I think it's called yes universe
yeah yes universe podcast and they were
asking me about with the girl name was
Phoenix lady finger lady Phoenix they
were asking me about bombing women with
the lab so you had a bad set well not
tonight six brought a TV credit and I
killed it bro for five minutes
and first time ever bro like I got off
yesterday I went outside the theater
people I got rush and people are like I
was saying autographs taking photos and
like
I didn't know brother they happen to my
life I never had a good set but it was a
good step and I was all on it bro
so cut to three months later me and Jeff
Garcia right
yeah dag on the road on the road me and
Jeff Garcia we go to he gets booked to
do a show called I was just joking it
was the urban club in the Houston bro
right next to a Hooters like across the
street and it that plane already
happening the boy was like one of the
urban club that opened up when [ __ ] was
hot that when Chicago was hot and that
cover the Tremont so they feel you know
a stomach we got a going down to right
so we're without clothes hot but not for
two Mexicans Father's Day
Lakers playing a super solids in the
playoffs oh yeah around a couple double
so telling that guy's foot so far I
started off bad what do you mean bad
well we get there the wages are going
home
damn the waitress all standard car
smoking cigarettes talking about what a
shitty like this this I don't know why
they call me in and when I'm here it is
on the way hand bro honey we know where
the [ __ ] before me he was just an
autograph three months yeah left the
pins me and Jeff Garcia in the winter
man and she ice I grew up first bro
they're only seven people in the
audience yeah and I'm look you know
every time I look to the right there's
is like you know things you pee on it a
lot at the Colonel's your nose Rhino
cakes like a trough like there's a
trough size thing full of bull wiser in
Berlin Coronas
and nobody was in a bye bro I was
watching the I smell people in the
audience and I only had 20 meters of
material of our lucky 15 but a tire fire
for that killer party
I I got to the point where I was telling
I was telling now people are lost alien
people so what did you do before you got
here like what we doing well free will
you catch conversation bad dog and keep
going down then the next day bro
same [ __ ] yeah they say it won't be real
words bro they said a manager home
damn we next to the management is the
old man it would be just the owner of
promoted at the manager man he's go home
bad I'm about to kill this promoter
right now calling the bomb threat
they paid us in tears bro when they paid
us they try to cut us short right a
harder $50 short I'm both of us and at
the devil brought wait a leather jacket
bro with his name in the back so I guess
they got intimidated bro is it not dog
and then another kept flapping his
jacket here like the back is hit the the
lap went there bad boy and little studs
and recognized like the nice man baby
dies so any other way you're wearing
harley-davidson boots blood gauge like
the Terminator and they she kept
stopping these little boots bro like nah
dog you said this money 9 little argue
hey yeah oh the rookie brought accepted
a sandwich dog blue collar lifestyle
like you can't pay for what you deserve
you know the car tracks a cool fire and
we got our 400 bucks each that's how
much we were forgetting paid for two
shows young with what city were Ewing
Houston young Lewis they flew teams
brother comedy condo for that place okay
yeah well hear me now I walk it back and
we locked it we are we locked ourselves
out bro like we are no key and we don't
want to go back and tell that club man I
know it your way home
so so Jeff said just get [ __ ] you're
probably gonna come back tomorrow we'll
leave it to where you keep the door down
so I could get the door down bro like
[ __ ] it I'm Tubbs raw for my body so
you're slapping anaconda with the door
mr. Nobel where we keep the door down
this red became our bro and it was the
wrong card like a [ __ ] here boxers
Bruin Sox brought a tank top rattlesnake
when that book came out I ran bro like
old school I booked a bright took coffee
house bro down the street but at the
county line when he saw the wizard for
the first time the devil stood right
there bro Jeff Garcia stood there bro
that wanna [ __ ] reason with that fool
somehow that he has a gift of the job
but like [ __ ] comedians in the
punchline man I was thinking just knock
this fool out and take Liam out right
here the house a lot of the door he'll
wake up you know what the [ __ ] happened
so you wanted to take it were talking
too much in relaxed I'm lucky my brother
won here you know like but this isn't
even thinking that takes it had girls he
had the right
Kilis yeah thinking about so you know
sooner or later somebody will stay after
that [ __ ] happened just call the police
just let you listen tagged pocket cut a
police dog telling what happened
you can feel secure dag I don't believe
in the police who still is a man we're
staying at the other condo over there
ready to give the address he gonna get
that number for that house
and then gonna come back and fix that
with door tomorrow morning man so
[ __ ] do that that out after that [ __ ]
bro it was fun we go back to our condo
and it was unlocked it was unlocked we
don't go in there man laughs pack and
leave
he laughed all night we can't be coming
out taking turns with our boxing he
could have killed us try still looking
for you ain't fix his door Logan Las
Vegas those type of character ma'am a
little guy with a hat and a big guy with
long hair you guys are his reason for
wanting to build the wall he remembers
for 20 years ago the wall give me my
daughter my picture about last night I'm
chachi showed up Manny Bravo
but a lot of people talk about how hard
they are when people kick in the door
and all he was probably surprised and
scared as you guys were how do you got a
gun even though it says reassuring oh
just kidding me a bit we had dogs we
will be dead dog - so we're waiting for
my fat leg oh yeah yeah yeah Oh Dickie
buy so they probably got a little bit of
the leaper able to drag that foot on the
street then it happened to you that that
man in the road like anything crazy like
that when you're on the road like cuz I
don't like sometimes convenient other
pickup and then they have a man bro I
hope he not listening but I'm me and
Benny men are we leaving we're leaving
portable and oh and um would you Riley
with buzz bro
that for him to record a bro damn [ __ ] G
Robbie hit three cars dang I hit one car
once
yeah like dog when I can see just been a
bunch of ticket to the DMV got my driver
license back I was all happy brought
here a quick little boss at DMV and when
I reverse I hate to car scared dogs and
fun like somebody hit me dog yeah it's
surprising your body like a jerk the
[ __ ] pilot club the man I saw watch
your D bro you're making hot dogs your
flute ass I wanted to I'll be back
tomorrow but Tampa we did a beer run bro
it's how crazy I was basically talk we
walked from [ __ ] the projects are the
way the rounds bro you're done [ __ ] like
that by rows of our high schools right
now nothing else but yeah he rap about
happy [ __ ] day yeah there's nothing
happy to wrap the bottle guy there's a
guy I won't say his name but guy who
came out a president recently from the
projects that [ __ ] deal his
lifetime in there bro for shooting at a
helicopter shooting at a helicopter at a
police helicopter didn't shut it down
then grant their photo [ __ ] right there
all right I don't even know the shooting
person in public record look it up I
think I know who
yeah brother a helicopter bro he went in
and 78 79 at 18 17 came out recently day
huh that's the best to long to be in
prison tethered about how gonna get you
one of your shoulders when in prison
when it was black and white TV 7840
that's 42 years ago yeah but they
colored TV but he had money he went yeah
well no he went in when 19-inch
black-and-white TVs worth a [ __ ] if you
have one in your room yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah where he went he when he
went in prison it wasn't on TV oh yeah
we had a life hari
yes 2,600 2,600 car co-could Hohner was
Coleco even out yet no let even yeah
this is in the 70s you know let not even
I think maybe the first football game
might have been uh but not reelect
mobile head yeah I love that game how
that game was the [ __ ] was still one bad
mother-- want to buy the land
get it off no one I love it Sears have
the real one you know knows how I had a
faint one two for Christmas we got this
bigger that big-ass vibrating board with
the yeah we got that [ __ ] that was a
trash when a deep demand will fall
that was some garbage man but uh went
went one of my worst row gig stories man
it was never it was it was I did I did a
show in st. Louis right the club owner
was a ex-heroin addict
and his hands was biggish his hands look
like he had on boxing gloves his hands
was like fat as hell
and uh so he was for some apparent
reason he was just brave you
I mean we just prayed for some apparent
reason I guess he was a heroin addict so
Lewis plans you know so I'm in st. Louis
or whatever and I'm performing and the
audience wanted me to rap
oh man look like a rapper yeah freestyle
rap from Detroit that's right doing
comedy
so they got Megas I didn't rat right
yeah chicken bones that you got any
throat [ __ ] they started booing right
but I've been moved before it doesn't
matter being booed and [ __ ]
so anyway long story short the owner was
like you didn't finish your set and I
was like I could go back onstage and
finish this [ __ ] you know I'm saying he
was like well I'm not gonna pay you all
your money that's dance somebody else
told me that that he said he not gonna
pay me all my money so I walked up to
him I like him and I talked to fair I'm
eatin he was loud as [ __ ] and it was a
lamp look people beat your ass but I
couldn't cuz I'm in st. Louis around his
people yeah I was so mad at his mom
[ __ ] heroin addict did you have uh do
you have a flattop back in those days
yeah no I had a I had a UH my I was just
losing the front of my hair so I was
still here I was still lining up blaming
it on a barber barber man so did he pay
you though he end up paying me down
because he saw that okay when I first
got to town
everything was a setup I felt like it
was a setup I heard saying losses like
like to make your money back so it's a
coma date or date day um alter called
the coma oh my god dirtiest [ __ ] you're
that guy huh yes yeah me him was about
to fight - yeah that guy stood up a to
her boy said over here monkey on your
food home and give me a ride came here
to a barbershop and then tell you it
lady be new at the airport yeah somebody
nobody no money he was sitting at
emmalin with the money he was supposed
to pay me he was gambling I grabbed his
arm man they pay me a check I was like
Annie pay you know check give me my
money so he opened a while he showed me
all my money he's like I got your money
and did he set on a kept gamma I said no
give me my money what coupons yes so he
finally paid me he was mad as [ __ ] I
thought I was done I was trying to
gamble with my money anyway um when I
first got the st. Louis the promoter to
check me in the hotel he said you say
hey he checked me in a hotel and they
was like you want one key or two let me
get two keys he handed me a key and put
a key in his pocket
that's weird [ __ ] are you doing you
don't put yo key so I waited he left and
I change brooms you know I mean the
Detroit move
that's always weird to that gig whenever
you show up to a check-in and the
promoter gotta be there check in with
you later yeah if you ever see fly ask
for up in the Hitmen by celeea or
Bakersfield he showed up chick in the
room the Gilman's key he goes to a room
and there's this [ __ ] big fat mess
can't do ironing just came on a blood in
blood out right what's up man we do it
in here I was so Steven fly I'm George
I'm gonna teach other show I guess we're
bunking together
damn and what do you do when that
happens zero you suck it up bro get your
target your death pathetique and yeah
the cost of those how'd you pay with mr.
st. Louis what happened after you switch
rooms we all switch rooms and we was
bought we was about to he saw that I was
willing to fight for my money you know
what I mean
and he laughed did he end up a me and it
was a punk ass comedian stand behind him
he was like
they exist yes I can't remember the
[ __ ] car boy he's a straight-up [ __ ]
I cannot remember his name man he lives
in st. Louis he's a straight-up don't
[ __ ] with the ball Lucas again he was
standing behind me telling a heroin
addict don't pay me right are you have a
mirror behind
oh my god I told her here I said man
[ __ ] what he talking about money my
money why you think the people that
don't have the balls to step up all the
people who get got ya know what I mean
yeah for every one of y'all who step up
probably 10 20 people who just won't
don't say [ __ ] yes take the loss yeah it
was some crazy ass roll stories man Eric
Blake my boy yeah he called me one time
he was like hey man and can you I can't
do it man can you go do this funeral and
I was like okay yeah he put half behind
you I think it's a funeral like up
somebody grandfather pathway right a
funeral of a funeral Oh theory on that
sound like it work economy at a funeral
like somebody died somebody Goldie
Leonard fine young man you know Bernie
Mac used to do funerals I get to the it
was a bat it was in a backyard in
Compton oh man you're doing two funeral
yes
you get there's a go to the wall the
tubular I did I needed right this was
years ago I had to catch up I got
dropped off there and caught a bus back
all right it was I was times was lame it
was past ously I had to take the funeral
for my little latina you know we gotta
do what y'all do for ya so I get there
man and I found out it was a funeral of
a three year old girl yes her father was
a suspect oh my god [ __ ] out on stage my
dog stage and I find out what's what's
going on with pilot so I'm gonna stage
that my man just [ __ ] up like I have a
break and this okay I start getting
heckled there's no color you forensics I
start getting heckled by crackhead that
was an audience there's cracky who's the
witness he was tearing me up to what
they just went through his tragic so
they laughing yeah after the show -
crackhead tells me he's like look man
don't feel bad I used to write for
Richard Pryor like yeah yeah Joe shut up
fool this is a funny ass crackhead do
and I just stood on stage and let's let
him destroy me what do you say though it
was like come here where's your shell
I wish I was there we're gonna show what
time to where the heckler will [ __ ] it
up all the comedian's bro j-roc yes oh
my god he called out for Hill man I
guess what we got tow truck drivers
doing comedy though he's all he's all
God man you dirty dog are you sure you
are you sure you look like a tow truck
driver homie the room went silent and we
all [ __ ] dime on stage now he don't
heckle me no it was it was it was Jeff
after him and then Jeff goes on stage
and he's all what's up with the you were
show show the time was so what you shave
your legs dawg
you look like Armenian is that a [ __ ]
big dog in a minyan song and then
they're full got offstage and goes up to
this fool handily dad wanna [ __ ] with me
but he's tough [ __ ] he starts killing by
[ __ ] with the audience so the old
lady with black hair like real black
hair and shiny makeup hey everybody
believe me okay all his life he make fun
of that person there all the way to the
back of the door let me come with the
suit someone with a black guy it wasn't
no we seen him at a quite Canyon and
started hanging out and then we seen
them a little bit at King Taco and then
he disappeared and then we seen him a
week later at quiet kated again
one day when I was at this [ __ ] got
jumped a tree and then we seen him again
like [ __ ] three years ago for the
Raider game next week next week on boy
you're a gas station this oh [ __ ]
so this weekend I'm babysitting I just
had a newborn baby oh yeah Castle you
had a baby I had a baby man I don't know
I heard somebody was pregnant
me neither I was man oh you guys didn't
plan for her nope it was a mistake I
know
[ __ ] me I said that to Jose Huizar Brody
jess.joy yeah man so I got a son now so
oh it's a boy
how many kid you had to - yeah - you
know it's so messed up about that the
day I found out my girl was pregnant was
the same day I found I got approved for
my vasectomy true [ __ ] I was done with
kids you know what I mean and I was like
you know I don't know more kids to [ __ ]
you know 45 now by the end of more kids
and I get it I get an appointment
he was doctor was like yeah you good
proof of vasectomy my girl came over she
was like I'm pregnant you selfish [ __ ]
you should Latino her blood she black
what go back to it again
somebody who RG Quesada I was with the
girl that George Lopez kicked out of
kicked out a couple of years ago in
Phoenix Arizona was crazy so your lady
got kicked out bro oh you hooked up with
her after she got kicked out then she
said something and he said something to
her he called her a name or something
like oh yeah I was live I would viral
yeah they hooked up
I don't even know this guy's story he
just wants to hang on so many who do
from Oreos tortas what's up basically
told you guys what you up or you guys I
got a big show next week in Boyle
Heights we're at at the Paramount show
they're the 22nd the next week after
yeah man it's yours the 15th so one week
from today tickets are on sale on
Eventbrite biggest show ever February
yeah no no January January 15 so week
away God and man biggest show I've ever
pulled from my own you know from our own
art and my own music I'm excited bro
show hits please wait would you please
call no the Paramount or word Rosa
Riverside at the court center yeah I got
some homies who do shows out there know
what James and yeah
cuz they have a hip-hop night there once
a month right common ground surgery a
common ground yeah those are the homies
oh [ __ ] I forgot to tell ya so next week
go for it up I mean I'm doing Edgewater
casino in Laughlin Nevada the club yeah
the club I've been des seen oh yeah
I'm doing it with this 16 17 18
something like that I'm in Lake Havasu
I'm in Lake Havasu the 15th dude I'm in
[ __ ] Arizona or Nevada the whole
would let hole and all next week I don't
know you know I know I'm doing Edgewater
casino you can hit you up on your of yes
hit me up on my Instagram is a screen my
initials a see the tha comedian one word
keep it together a see the community
what else that crackheads a dog oh man
are crack here with oh he look at his
shoes
he took my pants he said because I used
to run the streets is where it said man
do it he put me she was three no
harvester girl shut up to harvester
Carly to lose
Paul Rodriguez from the Waco Texas Jase
TZD stay zo that's the homie right there
was food this weekend I met Tommy T's
and Pleasanton January 9 through the 12
Sylmar California our Spanish show at
Casa Torres 8:00 p.m. be there at 5:30
Dallas Texas Addison in from January 17
to the 19 Tijuana Mexico
January 22nd at Spanish or Spanish or
Spanish or Antigua bodega de papel Santa
Cruz California January 25th at the
catalyst Club was full Pasadena
California our Spanish show
January 26 at the Ice House Santa Ana
California filming my next special
January 27 English show sold out
Cheryl 28 Spanish or fight tickets left
Wow Visalia and Fresno are sale now for
February 14 and February 15th shout-out
to the homey who's here today from
cannabis rich
kind of is from Boyle Heights
representing man you know it's [ __ ] I
somebody throw some real [ __ ] no
Outsiders coming in kind of it's rich
and stuff man
and so it's some weeding no trip no trip
to the shop I came to you this openness
to smell it this is and got the Primrose
I think it's a pre-rolls I think no I
just open up this last couple months
mass shells on the cannabis raise your
sperm so bro you know I already got the
perspective me man but I should have had
this you got it you got you got it I got
snipped up man it's a beautiful thing
beautiful go get snipped up back to me
his daughters took him to get it
brothers January 22nd to Paramount
another teacher Brewer my to your
favorite ballet cannabis rich where you
okay that rich put it over those runner
legs then okay Santa Anna all right man
yeah man before you get you a show go to
cannabis rich get yourself lit and then
come live with us in Espanola yeah yeah
what's up full podcast dr. Lena Carter
Janos Verdean hey beautiful here fool
catch you at those two mines lots of
love from Santa Maria ciao santa maria
maria' back in a day but when i perform
at that um VFW so Pearman rana was
across the street yes it was
they kidnapped somebody what's up - your
show it's next week so one week from
today
how much are the tickets ticket - twelve
bucks so you get them on Eventbrite yeah
it's it's a steal I'm walking with an
entire band a eight piece band doing my
entire album with the live band
rendition every song I've got hunger I'm
gonna do eight tracks and a couple
couple of collabs like you know remix
the songs and are you doing the
will.i.am song no I'm not doing that
Valda wander rocking she's super dope MC
la she's amazing so it's gonna be
awesome show
staff there's all Stephanie gurus you
better get ready cuz I splash beats like
sauce on spaghetti
yeah and I love my month beginning work
what's up bull shut up - Lisa last night
for making a badass soup at the house Oh
would you make shallow the papacy Rajas
secret so she got these Anaheim chilies
rose to your [ __ ] and then Ben
I've made a broth and put potatoes in it
and then closed it off with with some
hard-ass cheese
you didn't bring any you vegan out -
there's none left
you know I cut down a lot of meat they
see the kind of comedian man that I see
on television late at night bro first
man I feel like watching television with
my boxers if I'm gonna go to sleep or
what JC's playing some kind of nurse or
doctor he plays this basketball court
somewhere oh how was it your movie
remember yes oh man you know you right
yeah yeah right right yeah we wrote we
shot a feature man my first feature you
know I'm saying Rodrigo was in it and
Alfred his twin
[Laughter]
shut us off it rollable that Footwear at
$1,200 oh yeah every gay brochure yeah
my Detroit players so we are on the
dollars in two days
we just finished we just I just wrote my
pilot and my pilot my boy and we just
finished shooting man my first TV show
so it's gonna become a job so thank you
big dog man yeah it's calling Alan you
know it was called friendzone what we
change the name to Alan or whatever and
I have an appointment when I leave hit a
day man I got to go get braces though
Missy my teeth my teeth used to be
perfect right what happened I got my
wisdom teeth taken out two years they
shifted and it shifted as you get older
your teeth yeah I had him twice was a
teenager but then because the way I got
him when I was on welfare and they
didn't say for retainer no they didn't
cover a retainer luckily two new told me
that was they didn't pay for a retainer
in the first one so they shifted
immediately six months later I had to
get braces again so welfare paid for
that again Medicaid retainer no retainer
but I was I started working at that
point and I was 15 I lied and said it
was 16 so I could get a job and then I
paid for my own retainer but but my
teeth have shifted again lately and so I
have to are they constantly shift my
life I'm going to show you our picture
of how my teeth was two years ago they
want to put braces on kids at 9:00 now a
turtle with teeth 1gk I said I want to
know what other crackheads had you
smoked weed my [ __ ] was perfect my whole
life my whole life that little turtle
back in the shell dog that was two years
ago man yeah I'd like to wax
he saved a sample photos you smoke we do
know I don't smoke yes I've already said
why don't you smoke weed
it doesn't inform me didn't every didn't
you know what it never did nothin from
me into two years ago well that [ __ ]
around with Greg Wilson and Rachel Doug
great was the Greg Roshan show my fault
and Rachel no it's Greg Ricardo Wilson
now is it they got me hive hell man I
was [ __ ] up loving it right before a
show and before that had when was the
last time you had smoked man I haven't
smoked in about 20 years because it
never did nothing for me it should
change though I should change it's like
I was high and I had a show like we was
smoking we were doing a Comedy Festival
and I was in it we was in the alley we
smoked it I hit it like once or twice
and then I was high as hell I was scared
of [ __ ] and then they called my name and
I went onstage and I was I killed it I
cuz I was so focused Haley I was like
don't be have don't be happy I killed a
man but that was I've never been happy
for my life that was that was the first
time we got four more times ago right I
know she just right and I you know I had
sex had before once after that I don't
have to be too high on stage was about
to high on stage I start talking faster
than I'm thinking yeah yeah yeah do you
I mean cuz man when we first met he was
like he was like 34 year old version he
has sex with you how he was he was 25
year sex okay it lit up our room oh you
you have sex with a person I was 18 you
did honestly okay look YouTube y'all can
say there's nothing wrong but that's
[ __ ] weird
sex the first time we just turn 18 so
the first time is my sec no no no you
know what's our first pregnant when
you're 17 no 18 I remember I remember
the girl and this gets to in high school
yeah Barry team oh [ __ ] so 18 and you
had a baby in a dream yeah a next year
damn so the first time you hear sex you
know second time yeah second you got
somebody pregnant you know but that's
actually good about 25 yeah I was like
doing whatever they used to tell they
should those pictures like sex education
of people with herpes and [ __ ] you don't
want to be that person or we don't want
to be that person yeah that's that's a
colloid that bad so yeah yes
you know I caught crabs
toreano oh my god perhaps is the best
thing that's like 7ds though this is in
a 90s when people have pubic hair Martin
what time you got what get their modest
how'd you catch it huh man I caught it
hooked on you twice from the same girl
nice two are just crap just cry I mean I
didn't ask her but you know said Brad
bugs and everything huh we had a cup we
had a kind of mom and I call crackers is
all on you we can do the condom so I
call crabs and then I had to go get this
little calm you know get the yeah cuz
crabs are smart you can't even shave
them you can't shave your pubic remember
scabies yeah you know or in Tampa and he
was working at The Improv he said his
dad was a biker you see him like once a
year and he caught crabs for one of his
dad's girlfriends he was burning him off
with cigarettes that's [ __ ] up and he
was like nine yeah it's real common to
catch toilets you get him off policy
crawling in the army
go to girl you caught an army but not
curl to Joseph Benson and Danny Carly
yes when I was 16 and it was flying
everywhere
and then a girl called me I even know
how to react to [ __ ] at that age it was
crazy because when you first when I
thought it was a piece of land so I
touched it didn't start running oh my
god yeah and then she and when I got
that calling them all out I was cured
and then she called me back she was like
hey my parents are gone
call me once the bumpers tape does your
house meld I would even walk in there
dog back in the day that would look that
is the best thing to catch if you don't
ever catch an STD yes that is the best
thing because some vicious shelter and
gonorrhea best thing to catch other than
that well you know I don't know well I
don't know anything else other than that
gonorrhea yeah damn huh yeah Wow I
thought it was bad catching feelings
[Laughter]
those are the two best thing in the
catch I had them I've said I had the
crabs but those are the two easiest
things to get rid of so no hearing
vaginas then I thought that the thing
yeah her vagina
shut up to Molly so last I love you just
other week in Ontario and your host
called me Coco left my ass off like
where and why
sérgio Pena I'll cover your junior
Pleasanton I'll see you there on this
weekend like Coco solution like a fool
my skelita what are the album gonna come
on I'm working on new stuff right now I
dropped the new video on YouTube got the
Zoot Suit with the homie McGrady Oh G so
you could check that out right now it's
a brand new song called
rather get high we dressed up in suits
who's got the lowriders and my god
cheese it caused the big fuss and
everything everybody was real pumped up
about it
what's up for next week we're gonna have
probably my brother angel Karl in he's
been asking when we do the podcast Dinah
Karl in what so as far as he'll be back
people yeah man oh man taking everybody
who showed up to the Ontario improv and
with awesome stone up shows China -
Roger Lopez
Larry Bobo Brown little evil Torres
Johnny rocky Vinny Lisa that do they
helped us into the green room we tore it
up also stand-up live chuck Bartowski
mout there man that [ __ ] was fun
they kicked out two people or two fights
it was time Happy New Year man people
were just a really good grow the prom
dress trained on that
yes reign long table long like she was
modeling
next week I'll be an Addison improv
people it'll be Row three Torres I think
Bartel know Keith Manny and March and
Rizzo victim well that what so well you
performed waited before during the week
I really to be a walk Quixote bro
oh man while coyote how'd you know about
walk healed who told your buddy
um Larry brought you out there I did I
did I did some room somewhere maybe it
was a ha ha ha
I didn't up Steve fly and Jeff Garcia
but I thought we got a room over here
dad yeah yeah they plugged me into a
George George Perez they plugged me into
the Mexicans cuz uh what's in Larry
Omaha brought you there the first time
cuz then I remember you getting offstage
and Willie never says is this about
anybody's off he's funny bro yeah oh
there yes Larry Omaha yeah yeah Larry
Omaha you know brought me up there man
introduced me to the homeboy over here
you came out Howie Bell oh yeah when
your brothers rushed me at the mall man
y'all been doing good bloods out here
yeah he [ __ ] put honey oil and
[ __ ] green weed and while we do
Bloods too I mean were you guys smoking
right here
chronic dog I would holler yesterday
how's he doing doc he's good man we did
earthquake radio show yeah hell yeah
yeah we did
today what's up everybody who's ready
for World War 3 man he trippin 80 come
on man you know bomb the [ __ ] out of
Iran in two SEC's you try not to get
heat try not to get out of office they
impeached his punk ass and he was like
[ __ ] shout out to everyone woods
Oh Daniel just joined in Happy New Year
least our sister-in-law over there she's
just not joining an additional family
[Music]
you only talk to to talk to two people
of my family anymore that's it what's up
happy holiday happy holiday back ever
get ready for more holiday good holiday
everybody
yeah holiday I knew I was dealing with
the baby we didn't mean nothing he's
been alive man watching the sleeves it's
rough it's always like CUDA watch what
people eat like everybody and I'm Lisa
Lisa I'm sister-in-laws house they do it
baby bro like like Christmas is uh trees
trees it's like like you want to go to
the flowers for like Santa's Village
they go through although it wants to
harm or Christmas movies and cool oh
dear didn't one of our I saw him
watching these movies of camera watch
80s movies out so I'm gonna road and I
saw like a couple of movies yeah well
they were there watching another like it
ended out and ended with the dad and his
son and the wife lighting a Christmas
tree bro like it was a kind of sentiment
oh oh there are so like a woman getting
beat up a crispy
for Christmas maker I shout out to Marla
Reina salt are all mad but but then you
go to somebody
some people's house is what they're
eating you like come on man projects no
morning you're gonna go make a plate
make sure that plate nobody like that no
more like like I saw this dude mom was
making a big batch of spaghetti
oh hey go to a Christmas dinner and when
we get there happy with a tamale
for dinner yeah our tamales we are
non-stop this whole Thanksgiving
tomorrow
yeah even Thanksgiving we had well not
December and right in the start of
December we make tamales far for tour
yeah we took the hottest happy shows
[ __ ] tamales made more money than we
did at the door on some nice tamales
left my ex is back y'all big on tamales
for holidays I was tired of that [ __ ]
Isaac now thinks of Christmas as tamales
were you even though Mexican tamales are
using those banana leaf wrapped tamale
it was that the Mexican ones man okay I
mean it good but after a while I'm like
I'm sick of this [ __ ]
I love it so Christmas ham yeah how was
grandmas the [ __ ] I'll go to other
people's house a to that I live next to
Emilio and living next to Armando
Castillo something I worry me Leo making
a bunch of pancakes no a bunch of
tamales there are a man our mom whose
wife will make this this [ __ ] ham
that tastes like brown sugar basically
and yeah it was crispy Bravo bomb
I took her half of it home he was go to
somebody's house and you never had that
type of food but at the bar we end up
eating all of it
oh yeah yeah that's how I would I'm that
guy bro I never knew that [ __ ] was at a
Super Bowl they had if I go to release
our sister-in-law how the pundit I
pretend I don't know be in and everybody
fall to sleep only thing I ever had that
was bombers [ __ ] is a mac and cheese
with chorizo and cheese no no as a
whiteboard ROFL in a box he doesn't like
it because he thinks of it as a side
dish only but it's a whole meal
sometimes you could make it as a whole
yeah my mother used to make it but she
went did she make it too with the cheese
- it was ridiculous oh my god
and we eat it with the dressing and a
turkey is [ __ ] but if you when I just
see mac and see I don't eat it you know
I mean I gotta have everything else with
there's a thick layer of baked cheese on
that now man that damn she and did she's
made the we're fed cheese with it down
the big the brick government Reagan
great
that [ __ ] was amazing I see people like
eating it but like you're right man I
gotta have the mac and cheese something
now that yeah he'll alone like if I see
that little shitty mac and cheese with a
little
yeah I see how I was in a Russell Peters
john-boy I'm Azrael
they were Tory and they were somewhere
and Dubai and that will had a mac and
cheese with lobster like a fried butter
yeah I've never ate good I must to make
that she was torn at home so you like
mega cheapest Ridolfi they were married
I grew up on the kraft mac and cheese to
make it spread out so i should never
look orange brew water that's not like
my night look chili was for for four
years
I thought you can drink Chili's like you
oh my mother chili was because you know
we were poor as hell and she's
forgetting noodles in it she's really
stretchy I don't like man like I like
good barbecue but don't like that
barbecue that vinegar
that little party got a little tang glue
twins
I was like man more barbecued about that
thing again it's their own sauce but
there's no difference I thought about
jus that in like South Carolina makes
barbecue like I like the Texas like the
Texas joint like the smoky st. Louis so
Detroit is water and vinegar
Detroit is different that's eight miles
that I know my mother's house and then I
know like other [ __ ] cuz we would you
know my mother we we split a Big Mac
four ways I remember that was Big Mac
for big that's a big and we split them
[ __ ] for we was really poor growing
up man
you know so I took my mother got a [ __ ]
together and you know we got we started
balling in his [ __ ]
everybody got a Big Mac there everybody
big night and a small fry yeah so yeah I
mean we saw that McDonald they were
little back there thought it was a
little was hell it was sad I decided
it's almost yeah when did your mom get
her [ __ ] together what do you mean by
that I was 13 she went to college and
then um cuz my she went to cop not my
mother she retired but she was a social
worker but she went to college got a
degree got a job and you know because my
father was taking care of the house but
he he was an alcoholic you know I mean
so he's a [ __ ] off the money and you
know trick [ __ ] yeah he was a bar he was
a problem in the house so my mother was
like okay enough of this [ __ ] so she
went this clean was stretched out like
that chili yeah my father he was a buddy
was drunk as hell and he fell out one
time in the snow and my friend saved my
father's life he was he was an early in
the morning he was doing a paper route
and my friend hurt my father was buried
in the snow so my friend ran over there
and he recognized my father's all
hypothermia night or what he dropped he
didn't know this is happy that way he
stood there he would have been yeah if
he stood he would just dad free would
have been frozen
leave that man alone you know it was
nothing fun we to us to wake up my
father was gone for about three or four
days that was nothing we you know we
went him looking for you know I'm saying
yeah my friend found him do he would
have died all my friends their their
mothers got their [ __ ] together whatever
around
same age around 13 14 yeah my mom didn't
we just stayed poor everybody else all
of a sudden that girls were like getting
their hair done every week and it was
like what what happened but I think
their moms like went back to college and
it's starting to pay off
would you look at your mother like where
you going oh I got a job I got a job and
I started helping out the house and she
was kind of getting off welfare no but
it was tough because welfare paid for
our health care right so it was hard for
her to quit her or to go and get a
full-time job because we would have lost
our health care right yeah stay right
below the poverty line right there you
good that was tough you got to get the
man out the house and if you stay right
there you're good but or you want a man
that's like she couldn't get a better
job
Yeah right not that she did anyway after
welfare in debt but still just what's up
fool what's up fool yeah Bob made me cry
my mother my father get drunk two men by
like [ __ ] drunk bro I went to a point
where he can't he too drunk to turn the
key here in the house mmm so he'll just
pass off by the door and I'm all sigh
light like joy water is she [ __ ] with
him yeah oh dude he's the guitar like it
was his job you know what do you drink
Oh Mohawk Baca it was you can start a
car with that [ __ ] that's petroleum
cheap he used to keep it in his back
pocket when you open the hangar
he's real alcoholics go after the stuff
you can't hardly smell vodka you like
level 5 he when he was 19
he went to an alcoholic
[Laughter]
he never told me that story
yeah you know my whole life when I see a
father and a daughter together it's
weird to me it feels weird that bonding
I see the 65 year old guy with a 25 year
old son on to my show yeah
how together come to common skill yeah
man you like my dad for a comedian yeah
it was weird man I thought your dad
right yeah I'm cool my dad I mean he was
around but we're not never build some
[ __ ] together
he showed me a dude that went to high
school with them and he's all you want
to do drugs I'm all like what smoke weed
no like real [ __ ] drugs look at that
guy with the high school of that dude
my book is thrown karate kicks if you
still see him my dad's age my dad 70
don't know and he [ __ ] started doing
PCP when he was in high school dawg yeah
you know and then there's [ __ ] people
just [ __ ] up people in the
neighborhood that are still kind of
around yeah there's a lot of [ __ ] up
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
my daughter communicated a nose on
Instagram like every day try it
but like 9 we will call it my mom talked
for two hours on the phone my God my mom
bro me my daughter talk every day like
me or my daughter
she's 27 27 and a 0 year old baby I was
a baby and me her talk every day which
is like that's cool yeah everybody like
damn you do your daughter talk every day
like we talked every day
I guess mess my dog me and my [ __ ] me my
daughter like you and your man I thought
that was one of your older neighbors you
[Laughter]
know I'm so I forgot all about that I'm
glad I'm glad you brought that up do you
know how they you know [ __ ] up that is
that I thought that him and his father
was just amazing you know I mean the day
was that close that's tough that's how
[ __ ] up my life was then I got my damn
you or your father hang out and y'all he
built your house right yeah we built
that house in 2002 yep me damn I tripped
out to attend well we were to go pick up
Sebastian Cetina his house yeah and like
his house
I heard about I asked the wrong question
I said you get moving all the holes are
dirty right yeah yeah but you back to
this every axis
hello alone like stuff though Amazon box
today there's shipping [ __ ] yeah and
then whatever right and then we're
driving and his sister was drive by then
it's a bastard way of height to her then
that foot pulls over what's the matter
you're sad and they pull over they talk
yeah talk to the bomb yeah try to figure
this problem out before he leaves yeah
CIA little man broke the [ __ ] dog yeah
good man nobody had ever cared about it
but that my family had one time my
sister fall off the fight nobody runs
alone dad you eat her but why you riding
a bike watch you left you were too far
by myself family were if you hurt
yourself you're gonna get yelled at yes
no first aid kit for your well and about
you should've been doing that [ __ ] yeah
yeah it's your fault if you can hurt is
your fault why don't you what you doing
up at three point what the deal with the
problem but that will see the problem
and anything before you're buying I
could we ask a before you break your
teeth a dental you know me
[Laughter]
what's up when you close your motor
color every day no I don't but I live
right next to her so I get to see
everybody what so yeah crazy huncles bro
yeah of course you know color right yeah
yeah my dad side is much more cool but
my my mom's I grew up in the in the
projects with they were crazy they were
all coins to know forever and it oh go
ahead like he wasn't even slangin dope
no more but he would only slag to his
regular customer here like ten of them
but they Moffat will come knocking off a
rock throwing rocks at the window damn
Michael had like like clients for like
20 years yeah people who buy crack from
him for 20 who's the client 20 years I
seen these guys since I was like you
know six seven years old and some I
don't like what are you and my uncle I
mean we didn't really know as a kid
until you got older and you're like no
you don't work you got all this money
yeah the same customers bro like nobody
knew nobody old he never got locked up
just test to him the same batch of
people that were old bros okay I started
with over 20 level 49 crack you know
living I live in a 9 to 5 job and
maintain a family and a [ __ ] drug
addiction there's a lot I learned that
when I started working and you know
getting into the workforce and it was
I'm like this looks like one of my
uncle's clients right partying and doing
all this other stuff on the side even
though he's a manager of like in coffee
bean you know it was like I'm only going
to [ __ ] up these 10 people's life he's
like
I'm not gonna [ __ ] up my whole community
be a guide people there will be a guy
outside the house his house and that
fool had a [ __ ] truck parked double
parked on the street and this was a
full-on [ __ ] butcher gear butcher
butcher yeah yeah what tell his guy
named sway he [ __ ] trying to break
into the butcher factory next door the
[ __ ]
drop the gate how why the truck throw
that [ __ ] out and kick down the
[ __ ] gate drove four blocks
lubos inside left it there that will
store the fat and all the bad parts of
it blood even if it were if you were
took it somewhere they will chase the
part of the blood trail he stole the end
row like guts balls liver hurts we had
we had a crackhead in that neighborhood
named fede
everyone knew fede - he was hilarious
he's walking around with no shirt on in
the wintertime - he's walking around
with no shirt on and every time somebody
see him dare or everybody running his
street
around him and cuz he's a loved kung fu
movies so he thought he was Bruce Lee
and he was but I wha and people used to
just run and kick the [ __ ] out of him
but he's like everybody recorded he
would have been famous viral his name
was fede the crackhead meeting like like
to be this - crackling - being a project
he was 610 bro 611 did you colorful tree
you're a black beard dude bro
and I foot just come in there bro are
like like a tree big old tree by crack
bro and I'm calm brought some time to
blow like a man cool slammed up real
quick boy I don't really go and there's
no crack dang it's really kind of don't
wobble yeah because I thought booyah
could I forget when they came out of
prison like he was charged he was like
because I'm a teacher bro pause was us
at the time our souls like yeah I took
your willing muscles and some fool named
John Wayne they kind of John Wayne cuz
they had big cheeks he gave that for big
fat 20 and he goes want you to smoke
that [ __ ] right now for all of us
you sure yeah alright please put some in
there bro hold 20 bro hose a breath and
be little dragon bro and then our
forwards you go back here no Jack put
people's cars eggs crack hit myself just
talking about it broke me by my water
told me a long time ago
Rodrigo if I start doing comedy at 15 it
would have been over
[Laughter]
/ - what's up full shuttle - hey Steve
Abid again and a little Thank You Man
Cunningham yes indeed may I appreciate a
relation to Richie Cunningham I've no I
saw fool man I've I've no yard news man
I don't know how many years shut up -
that haven't been outside cannabis
cannabis rich I got the nice shirt and
the weed there you go it's a good
material in the church I know how always
oh yeah
don't forget people to pick up that book
this book I fatty you got 30 days to
read people
he broke somebody I broke a bottle about
his [ __ ] yeah it was a girl that
ended up dead inside of the tub of the
bathtub of his hotel room with that
broke in there
come on I read that he was trying to get
out of the Warner Brothers concert
better cuz do his old movies but they
had him on a contract soy the water
really got together with a guy front of
her examiner and they put it like
William went ran off her own campaign
the dirty tale
they ruin his life he directed movie
with a false name but